You probably know that plenty
of colleges offer classes
online, but if students need a
little extra help, more and
more of them are finding it
now for free on YouTube.
Kiet Do shows us what
could be the next
generation of online learning.
Going to a traditional old
school is, well, old school.
This is the worldwide
headquarters of the Khan Academy.
Inside this converted walk-in
closet could be
the future of education.
What we can do here is just
distribute this x plus 2y onto
each of these terms.
With a headset, an electronic
pen, and a zest for learning,
Sal Khan records short,
bare-bones, 10-minute
educational videos and posts
them on YouTube.
No big deal until you realize
there are more
than 1,500 of them.
So 3 plus 4 is equal to 7.
Covering everything from
basic addition--
The dimension of a transpose.
--to advanced linear algebra--
And he is the King of Prussia.
--to French history--
You now have $40,000.
--and Ponzi schemes, economics
mixed with current events.
70,000 people view his
bite-sized videos every day at
their own pace, all for free.
At the end of the day, what
makes this fun for me is the
idea that as many people
as possible could
benefit from it.
Khan started recording videos
back in 2006 to tutor an
out-of-state relative.
Since then, it's exploded, and
last year, he left his
lucrative job as a hedge fund
analyst and lives off
donations to Khan Academy.
The 33-year-old says the videos
can free up teachers to
focus on teaching instead
of lecturing.
So the teacher says go home,
watch these videos, and then
when we come to class the next
day, you have already watched
the lecture.
I don't have to do that
broadcast lecture to you in
the classroom, and we'll
actually do your homework in
the classroom.
Accessible, cheap, effective,
and sustainable teaching for a
wired generation.
It is making people think hard
about, well, what is the
proper role for technology
in the classroom?
So I do hope it starts a bit of
a revolution, but I don't
know if I can call myself
a revolutionary.
Call it education 2.0.
And we are done!
In Mountainview, Kiet Do.